this video will teach you how to check
your blood sugar level please watch the
entire video before checking your blood
sugar level learning how to check your
blood sugar level can help you make good
daily decisions about managing your
diabetes checking your blood sugar
involved sticking your finger with a
landset and testing your blood with a
glucose meter your healthcare provider
will tell you when and how often to
check your blood sugar and give you a
blood sugar target range try to keep
your blood sugar within your target
range
you will need alcohol wipes or soap and
water a Lancet which is a small needle
that fits into the landset device test
strips a blood glucose meter and a
logbook step 1 wash your hands with soap
and water and then dry them or use an
alcohol wipe to clean the finger you
will use for the testing site and let it
dry step 2 remove a test strip from the
container and put the cap back on to
protect the strips be sure to use a new
test strip each time you check your
blood sugar step 3 insert the test strip
into your glucose meter step 4 place a
new landset into your land set device
always use a new land set every time you
check your blood sugar
step 5 stick the side of your finger
with the land set to get a drop of blood
sticking the side of your finger rather
than the tip hurts less use a different
finger for each test to help prevent
sore spots you may need to gently
massage or squeeze the blood out of your
finger
squeezing your finger too hard may give
an inaccurate reading most Lancet
devices have a dial that lets you select
how deep the Lancet goes into the skin
if you get more blood than you need
dial the number down so the land set
does not go as deep if you do not get
enough blood dial the number up so the
land set goes in deeper step 6
touch the correct part of the test strip
to the drop of blood but not your skin
the meter will display your blood sugar
level on a screen step 7 write the
number into your log book be sure to
record your blood sugar level every time
you check it also use your log to record
things that may affect your blood sugar
such as illness exercise stress and
eating food at a party make sure to
follow up with your doctor regularly and
bring your logbook to all of your doctor
appointments you and your doctor may
need to discuss changes to your meal
plan physical activity or diabetes
medications